so many people look at walking as a very
trivial thing and sometimes they'll
think it's just kind of a waste of time
because think about how much production
or productive things you can do in place
of you know walking for 45 minutes well
after today's video that might change
your mind because walking is probably
one of the most therapeutic things you
can do and the majority of these
benefits I'm going to talk about related
to walking are things that you probably
have never heard before I mean we know
walking helps you you know maybe lose
some weight maybe reduce stress but how
does it reduce stress that's the
question the first point I'm going to
Dive Right In is this when you walk you
significantly lower your cortisol levels
even after a 20 minute walk so what does
this mean when you have high levels of
cortisol your body is in this adapt mode
it's adapting your physiology to your
environment to stress
so walking turns off that mechanism so
you're less in this flutter fight
sympathetic dominance mode in more in
the parasympathetic so that's why you
feel calmer that's why you feel less
stressed because now the body is not
stuck in this uh stress reaction mode
and so with lower levels of cortisol and
adrenaline you're going to feel better
even on DNA testing there's a certain
Gene that causes the person to hold on
to Adrenaline longer okay and the remedy
for that is to exercise and flush it out
not necessarily always high intensity
but some low intensity long walks all
right number two which relates to number
one
you're going to have improved creativity
and what I mean by that is more creative
thinking
think about this when you're in stress
mode and you have high levels of
cortisol
what is your level of creativity it's
pretty low it's almost impossible to be
creative when you're under stress when
you have high levels of cortisol and
this definitely relates to problem
solving as well because when you solve
problems you need creativity and when
you have stress you're not really good
at solving problems like you would if
you were more calm and you had more
creativity going on a long walk gives
you this new space this ability to look
at things a little bit easier it gives
you space between you and the problem so
the problem is not like all up here you
have space now you can kind of look at
it you can kind of play with it you can
come up with Solutions number three
which relates to number two this is
going to affect your overall mood you're
going to have less anxiety you'd be less
depressed all right number four the
mitochondria inside your cells which is
the energy Factory and most diseases are
associated with damaged mitochondria
they call it a problem with your
metabolism and that really relates to
how well that your cells are fed Fuel
and you get oxygen and Etc so when you
go on long walks you enhance the quality
of mitochondria you enhance the numbers
of mitochondria mitochondria become more
efficient at burning fuel and the better
your mitochondria work the less diseases
you'll have number five and this is
interesting exercise especially walking
increases
microbial diversity you'll have more
diverse types of microbes that's pretty
wild which is going to help a lot of
things it's going to help your immune
system it's going to help your digestion
it's going to help your energy and
number six walking improves or increases
your endogenous antioxidants what does
endogenous mean it means something from
within in other words your body has the
ability to create antioxidants and when
you do walks you actually create more of
your own antioxidants and this is
nothing to do with what you're eating
your body's just making more antioxidant
networks which is going to help you
fight off free radicals it's going to
actually help with longevity it's going
to help prevent a lot of problems all
right number seven walking actually
increases
your natural killer cells these are part
of the immune system and they actually
kill cancer cells and viruses well
walking increases the natural killer
cells all right number eight walking
improves insulin and glucose sensitivity
so if you have insulin resistance if you
have a problem with glucose
walking improves this to the point where
it can significantly decrease the
resistance to insulin which is going to
help your blood sugar so if you're a
diabetic or a pre-diabetic walking is
awesome and even if you have the dawn
phenomena where you wake up in the
morning and your blood sugars are high
going for a long walk can burn off that
sugar and that's what happens for the
first I don't know about 25-30 minutes
is you burn off all this extra sugar you
have and then you start burning fat all
right number nine
and this is
um interesting because yes it is true
when you walk you get more oxygen but
it's not about getting more oxygen in
your blood it's about what happens
between your blood cells and your tissue
cells are you absorbing more oxygen
from that blood saturation okay like
even if you do an intense workout where
you're breathing heavily right you think
you're getting all this air but it's
kind of like having a cup that's filled
with water and then you try to add more
water to it it's already filled it just
kind of flows over that's what happens
when you exercise intensely when you're
over breathing you're getting all this
oxygen but it's not being delivered into
the tissues in fact you probably feel
like you have to breathe harder to get
more oxygen into the tissues but here's
the key
it is true that you need oxygen right
but to deliver and transport that oxygen
CO2 is needed CO2 is not just a waste
product it's essential to make sure that
oxygen is delivered in deep into the
tissues so whereas certain type of
height intensity exercise is good for
certain things
walking is good for getting oxygen deep
into the cells because you're not
breathing too much you're not flooding
your body with too much oxygen you're
getting a nice balance of oxygen and CO2
which is the key to deliver that oxygen
especially if you breathe through your
nose okay you'll get like 20 more oxygen
if you're walking and for people that
walk maybe a little bit faster they are
generating lactic acid and that acid
tends to inhibit oxygen so what happens
in your blood is you have certain things
that are alkaline they're called
bicarbonates and that's going to help
neutralize dyslactic acid fairly quickly
and then the byproduct chemistry of that
is H2O water and carbon dioxide so your
body actually is getting CO2 from that
process as well all right number 10 bone
density increases when walking
interesting number 11 reduced
inflammation you're also reducing
stiffness but but Motion in general and
getting this oxygen to the tissues is
going to help reduce inflammation and
the last thing that walking will do is
enhance your vision and from several
different ways first of all you get more
oxygen to your brain and your retina is
a part of your brain sticking out into
your eyeball and also you're going to
improve insulin sensitivity which is
going to help your eyes your kidneys
your nerves because it's going to help
blood sugars so this is why you should
make walking a very important good habit
in your life now just to balance this
video I think the next video for you to
watch is the importance of high
intensity interval training check it out
I put it right here